[Música]
hola
como están como todos ustedes saben un
rostro dice más que mil palabras y como
todos pueden ver el rostro que está acá
es el rostro de una persona cansada que
podría ser cualquiera de nuestros hijos
nietos sobrinos
vecinos amigos en realidad el rostro en
particular no importa lo que importa es
el gesto cual gesto de ajustadas es el
gesto de una persona gritando pidiendo
ayuda como están hoy miles de niños
niñas y adolescentes en nuestro país
pidiéndole ayuda a los adultos para que
atiendan con urgencia sus necesidades
cuáles adultos bueno ustedes yo todos
pero bueno porque están pidiendo ayuda
bueno porque han experimentado en los
últimos años un apagón educativo que
está amenazando seriamente sus
oportunidades de futuro
y en qué consiste este apagón porque se
produjo este apagón se preguntarán
ustedes veamos esto con detalle como
todos ustedes saben al igual que en el
resto del mundo el sistema educativo fue
uno de los más afectados por la pandemia
que obligó de un día para otro al cierre
de nuestras escuelas
en todo el país
de un día para otro más de 1.200.000
estudiantes fueron enviados a sus casas
y esto afectó en particular a todos los
estudiantes pero sobre todo a los más
pobres y a los más vulnerables que son
los que asisten mayoritariamente a
nuestro sistema educativo
pero además
la pandemia profundizó problemas que
veníamos arrastrando antes y que no
habíamos resuelto como cual es bueno
como el bajo logro educativo de nuestros
estudiantes los bajos aprendizajes que
muestran vean ustedes en este gráfico en
la última prueba en la que costa rica
participó la prueba internacional pisa
nuestros la mayor parte de nuestros
estudiantes el 85% de ellos tuvieron
bajos desempeños en matemáticas en una
prueba que tiene seis niveles de
desempeño y la mayoría de ellos se
concentró en el nivel 2 o menos 2 lo que
significa que tienen problemas para
resolver problemas de matemáticas pero
también vean ustedes que también
avanzábamos otros problemas en este mapa
que ustedes vengan cada puntito que
ustedes ven allí es un centro educativo
con una orden sanitaria qué significa
eso bueno que es un centro educativo el
ministerio de salud ha cerrado porque
allí
que ahí no hay condiciones para que se
den las clases y bueno así estábamos
cuando llegó la pandemia
y a esto se sumó el apagón educativo que
les voy a explicar en qué consiste ese
apagón educativo lo que no sabe lo que
nos habla es que los últimos cuatro años
hemos tenido
interrupciones
acumuladas de nuestro ciclo lectivo en
el 2018 por una huelga docente que
tuvimos en el 2019 de nuevo otra huelga
en el 2020 por la pandemia y en el 2021
tuvimos un nuevo proceso por el tema de
la vacunación qué significa esto bueno
que hay niños hoy en cuarto grado de la
escuela que desde que entraron al primer
grado no han tenido un ciclo regular
completo o que hay muchachos en séptimo
y en quinto año de colegio que su último
año completo fue cuando estaban en
séptimo pero además el apagón también
significa que hemos tenido una
contracción de los aprendizajes y
habilidades de nuestros estudiantes vean
ustedes
en el 2020 cuando hubo que priorizar
contenidos en español por ejemplo
nuestros estudiantes no recibieron el 50
por ciento de los contenidos que debían
haber recibido según el programa y hay
años particularmente afectados como por
ejemplo segundo grado donde nuestros
estudiantes no recibieron el 62 por
ciento de los contenidos que debían
recibir o en 6º grado donde no
recibieron el 57% lo cual es muy grave
porque estos son los años en los que han
hemos tenido siempre mayores problemas
de repitencia qué significa esto bueno
que hoy tenemos niños y niñas en segundo
grado de la escuela que no saben leer y
esto es muy serio porque esto
incrementará en los próximos años si no
hacemos algo rápido lo que algunos
organismos internacionales han llamado
la pobreza de los aprendizajes es decir
de niños que cuando tienen 10 años no
saben comprender el texto
pero además otro componente del apagón
educativo es que tenemos una gran
cantidad de estudiantes desconectados
cuando nos fuimos todos a nuestras casas
y se suponía que todos íbamos a tener
condiciones para recibir educación a
distancia remota resulta que el piso no
estaba parejo para todos el ministerio
de educación primero nos dijo que habían
500 mil estudiantes desconectados
después nos dijo que eran 300.000
después nos volvió a decir que eran
400.000 no importa cual quiera de estas
cantidades estamos hablando de cerca del
40% de nuestros estudiantes
desconectados qué quiere decir eso son
estudiantes que aunque están formalmente
inscritos en el sistema no están
aprendiendo y les estamos negando su
derecho a la educación
por eso este apagón es grave y tenemos
que hacer un movimiento rápido para
volver a encender las luces de nuestra
educación pero ojo no son cualquier
luces necesitamos nuevas luces que
cambien radicalmente lo que veníamos
haciendo antes de la pandemia y que
evidentemente no estaban dando los
resultados que todos esperábamos por eso
hoy les propongo que tenemos que actuar
rápido y que tenemos
todos que planteamos la pregunta de cómo
encender las luces de nuestra educación
cada uno de nosotros eso es lo que hoy
tiene que preguntarse cómo encendemos la
luz de nuestra educación y bueno yo les
voy a proponer cinco ideas
para esta respuesta a la respuesta a
esta pregunta en primer lugar
necesitamos instalar en el sentido de
urgencia por la educación en la
conciencia y en la opinión pública
nacional necesitamos que todos
entendamos que es urgente encender las
luces de nuestra educación y les voy a
dar dos datos para que vean por qué es
urgente no sé si ustedes sabían que en
el último año
hemos tenido
y ha aumentado en nuestro país el número
de estudiantes
pobres el paso de 187.000 a 297.000 esto
es un crecimiento brutal
que hace que muchos de nuestros niños
estén con una serie amenaza de salirse
de la escuela pero les cuento un segundo
dato hoy
uno de cada cinco eventos delictivos o
venta de drogas ocurre a 100 metros de
nuestra de nuestros centros educativos
por eso si nosotros no comprendemos que
la educación es importante necesitamos y
que necesitamos que nosotros que
nuestros estudiantes no se salgan de la
escuela y del colegio porque porque si
se salen serán presa fácil de la
delincuencia y el narcotráfico algo que
no quisiéramos tener para nuestros
estudiantes
la segunda idea que les quiero plantear
es que
de nuevo abramos todas nuestras escuelas
tiempo completo y desarrollar los planes
de nivelación cuanto antes pero eso no
son cualquier es planes de nivelación
necesitamos colocar a la lectura en el
centro de esos planes de liberación que
nuestros docentes sean buenos lectores y
que nuestros estudiantes sean buenos
lectores porque digo de esto bueno
porque efectivamente si un país tiene
buenos docentes lectores y buenos
estudiantes lectores tiene un sistema
educativo de calidad
la tercera idea
necesitamos tener ambientes conectados y
qué quiero decir con esto bueno que
necesitamos que no tener no tener más
interrupciones en nuestro sistema
educativo en los próximos años ya sea de
manera presencial o virtual y por eso es
urgente que tengamos cuanto antes una
red educativa
conectada con internet de alta velocidad
eso es muy importante además necesitamos
docentes con competencias digitales por
eso es urgente que dejemos de poner
trabas y zancadillas a las propuestas
que ya tenemos en la mesa para hacer una
red educativa del bicentenario
también
la cuarta idea necesitamos avanzar hacia
la escuela del siglo 21 cuál escuela del
siglo 21 bueno esa en la que nuestras
aulas se convierten en verdaderos
laboratorios de innovación
y donde es fundamental que cambiamos el
perfil de los docentes y de nuestros
directores de los centros educativos
para que sean cada vez más líderes
pedagógicos y menos lideres
administrativos que sean investigadores
lectores
y que sean capaces de promover en
nuestros estudiantes el gusto por la
lectura aplicar el método científico
usar las tecnologías de información y
comunicación para generar conocimiento
necesitamos que cada vez más tengamos
funcionarios meros burócratas y
funcionarios más creativos que quiero
decir con esto bueno es que los
funcionarios o los burócratas
funcionarios más burócratas ven la
enseñanza como solo un puesto de trabajo
no se salen de la directriz que reciben
no van más allá y piensan que no pueden
cambiar nada en cambio los funcionarios
creativos saben que la enseñanza es una
oportunidad para reflejar su
personalidad para aplicar sus
conocimientos teóricos y sus
competencias didácticas para mejorar las
calidad las capacidades de sus
estudiantes y bueno finalmente
necesitamos como la última idea un
sistema educativo que ponga en el centro
lo que tiene que estar en el centro que
tiene que estar en el centro la relación
docente-alumno lo que pasa en el aula y
para eso necesitamos revisar la
estructura organizativa de nuestro
sistema educativo para que sean menos
burocráticas más flexibles más liviana
para que podamos
y canalizar todos los esfuerzos hacia
nuestros estudiantes y nuestros docentes
hoy más que nunca no podemos volver
atrás tenemos la oportunidad de dar de
nuevas luces a nuestra educación y de
reinventar nuestras formas de aprender
no perdamos la oportunidad nuestros
niños niñas y adolescentes están
esperando y no nos podemos darle el
gusto el lujo de fallar les todos
tenemos que aportar ustedes docentes
ustedes directores
autoridades empresarios gremios docentes
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
todos tenemos que aportar en especial
los políticos por eso les invito que en
este es éste en este proceso electoral
que hoy estamos empezando en el país
ustedes les pregunten a los candidatos
que van a hacer por la educación que van
a hacer por el apagón educativo para
encender las nuevas luces de nuestra
educación
porque bueno porque hoy porque nosotros
somos un país cuya principal riqueza es
su gente
una educación de calidad
es la mejor arma instrumento para que
nuestros estudiantes puedan cumplir sus
sueños puedan ser en el futuro
ciudadanos activos en nuestra democracia
pero más aún sean ciudadanos globales
plenos del siglo que les tocó vivir
nuestros niños niñas y adolescentes
están esperando basta ya de perder el
tiempo y encendamos ya las luces de
nuestra educación
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]